le bout
un début tout en douceur avec l'école de
musique à guyancourt la fête de la
musique a mis en avant les talents
locaux comme ses élèves clarinettistes
il ya toutes les formations je croque
quasiment tout ce produit c'est vraiment
le peut-être le moment phare de l'année
passée un choix en même temps on a le
droit de faire que du christ icloud
petite jazz mais ouais on aime bien
toucher un petit peu
à tous les sites à tous les styles
répartis au moment où ces deux là de la
bonne musique à la batterie on a vu les
choses en grand
cinq scènes et 40 groupes et artistes
tous les styles tous les âges et même
des renaissance les rockeurs de sans
limites se sont reformés pour l'occasion
[Musique]
c'est pour permettre sans limite d'âge
aa je vais te dire un truc moi j'ai 70
malin on a tous 60 ans qua non à
l'épaule huibers ton est potes depuis
mes collègues connaître une lisse et
quasiment n'a pas moi qui suis mon plus
vieux que des groupes qui se dessine à à
la professionnalisation comme les jam
haut-le-coeur qui ont gagné le tremplin
de la batterie l'année dernière et puis
d'autres effectivement qu'ils sont là
juste pour le plaisir qui répète une
fois par semaine
comme d'autres vont à la piscine au fond
du macramé ou du tricot chaque année ce
rendez-vous attire près de quatre mille
mélomanes
[Musique]